[Music]
hey you guys here we are again with yet
another installment in my halloween eek
week series all my
you know extra movie reviews that i'm
doing for the week of halloween uh
movies that i've really wanted to get
around to doing for a very long time and
for whatever reason just never got
around to them so these are ones that
are kind of like long overdue i guess
this one probably more than any other
ones this is one of the ones even way
back when we were first starting to
do movie reviews this was actually one
of the first ones that i think that i
wrote down on the list and for whatever
reason we just never really got around
to doing it
but
i'm finally remedying that situation now
this is guillermo del toro's 2001 the
devil's backbone
now
i'm not actually sure
now that i'm thinking about this this
might actually be the first guillermo
del toro movie that i've seen
or that i saw i don't remember i don't
think i saw it in the theater because i
don't think i was living in daytona or
tampa at that time and i'm really not
sure if it played in the theaters there
so i think maybe i saw it like a year
later
rented or something because i kind of
heard a lot of buzz about it i'd heard
his name but
you know uh as someone to watch but i
hadn't really seen any of his kind of
more big budget stuff
so what ended up happening with this
movie was that
um i don't know if uh if most people
know because i feel like a lot of people
don't talk about his really early movies
but uh back in 1993 he made a spanish
language film which this is too called
chronos which was sort of like a vampire
movie kind of but had a really um unique
spin on it
i actually will probably do a review of
that eventually uh one day too because i
think i have it on dvd back there i just
found it it was up in my attic the other
day when we moved but uh yeah it's
totally forgotten that i had it but yeah
so it's there
so he had worked on that and there was
like a lot of buzz about it so like i
said he ended up kind of getting a lot
of sort of bigger budget projects so one
of those uh was mimik which i think
ended up coming out in 1997
and i guess i kind of remember seeing
that back in the day but i don't really
remember a lot about it but i remember
like the production of that was kind of
a [ __ ] and he didn't really have
a good time on it and there was like all
this other kind of [ __ ] about it
and so right around the time that that
was going on and he was having a huge
headache with you know trauma with
making that movie uh something else
actually happened in his personal life
his dad was actually kidnapped in
guadalajara and was held for ransom for
like 72 days or something like that so
these two things happening in his life
at around the same time you know the
[ __ ] that was mimic and his dad
being kidnapped
sort of made him kind of like want to
get back to
doing something creatively that was more
like what he wanted like doing something
more independent
so what he did was he went back to this
script that he had written like 16 years
prior uh when he was still in college i
believe and that uh script was what
would end up being the devil's backbone
so he actually wrote the devil's
backbone the story um even before
chronos came out so this was like back
in the early 90s or whenever now i think
the original script uh was very
different than how it actually turned
out but you know so there were some
variations along the way i don't think
it was initially supposed to be set
during the spanish civil war or that it
was just kind of like um a kind of a sad
ghost story it has like some other more
fantastical elements but
honestly like the way it turned out
i really really love movies like this
like i said this gets compared a lot to
the others which also came out in 2001
and you know obviously the orphanage
which came out later which he actually
produced as well uh so it's that still
kind of vibe
also uh pan's labyrinth which came out
in 2006 he considers like the sister
movie to this film this one is more
low-key ghost story whereas pan's
labyrinth is more fantasy but they're
set during the same time period and they
and they both have this sort of
tone of
chill like everything being seen through
the eyes of children and kind of like a
fantasy element to it also uh this is
kind of like a running through line
through like a lot of del toro stuff is
that
usually the monsters whatever they are
whether they're ghosts or what have you
are not usually the bad guys uh it's
usually like humans
the the villains end up being humans and
the monsters or ghosts or what have you
generally end up being
just misunderstood or like trying not to
scare the humans but you know what i
mean so it kind of ends up like that in
uh the devil's backbone so what happens
in this there's a little boy named
carlos and this is set in 1939
during the spanish civil war
so carlos his dad has been killed in the
war
uh and he was fighting on this on the
side of the republican army it's the
republican army versus the nationalists
so he's uh so his dad is killed so he's
taken by these two friends of his dads
or you know acquaintances whatever to
this very remote orphanage i think it's
called santa lucia and it's sort of like
out in the middle of nowhere like in
this sort of blasted sand landscape or
whatever so he's taken out there and um
you know kind of put up
now interestingly this orphanage uh it's
all boys
and it has very prominently an
unexploded bomb in the courtyard
and so they come in and it's like
sitting there and he and they ask about
it and they're like yeah it was dropped
here a while back and it just never went
off and then they just came and diffused
it you know and so they it said it's
like too heavy to move and it didn't
bother moving it so we just leave it
there so it's almost kind of like this
very ominous you know this kind of omen
this thing that's like sitting there now
it doesn't take too long uh before
carlos arrives like after carlos arrives
for him to hear that this orphanage may
be haunted and honestly he pretty much
sees an apparition
within the first few minutes of him
arriving and can i just say that like
the apparition in this i like it's not
super flashy it's not and this came out
in 2001.
and the special effects in this i'm not
entirely sure how they did it's probably
cgi of some kind but it really doesn't
look because i know that there's like a
lot of movies that came out in 2001 and
like the special effects look kind of
like nowadays but the ones in the
devil's backbone still look great uh the
ghost it's honestly it's one of the
creepiest
ghosts ever it's like a little boy
and he has like these like really creepy
his eyes are like kind of like there's
like a pinpoint of light like in the
middle of them and they're kind of like
dark and stuff and he almost kind of
looks like
a porcelain doll like it's kind of
cracked and then he has this wound in
his head
that
just um like blood comes out of it and
like flows up out of it like almost like
it's under water so there's always kind
of like this swirling sort of like blood
cloud kind of thing and also when he
walks
you can kind of see like he looks sort
of solid but then when he walks you can
kind of see like every now and then you
can see like bones like sort of like the
x-ray but it's like really really subtle
and it's really really cool the way it's
done so carlos arrives at this place and
uh you know kind of immediately there's
kind of a bully character there that
starts picking on him but he's you know
he he turns out okay later on but he
starts hearing stories about
this little boy that was there because
he gets the same bed like when they put
them in the you know in all the beds and
everything they said oh he got santi's
bed now santi disappeared
the night that the bomb fell into the
courtyard and no one seems entirely sure
what happened to him so for a time like
the other boys tell carlos that there is
maybe a ghost
in the orphanage and they call him the
one who sighs because i don't know it
seems unclear if like the other boys
have seen him but they definitely like
hear him like going through the halls
and everything like that and it's kind
of creeping him out and i don't know if
they make the association at first
between him and santi because they don't
know you know they they just know that
santi disappeared and nobody knew what
happened to him however like i said
carlos did get a glimpse of
what looked like a creepy boy he he
almost kind of looked like a real boy
for a second because he kind of sees him
far away and it's like in the day and he
sees him in like a doorway so it's
possible it could be a real kid but then
it's like he turns back and he's not
there so not too long after he arrives
uh he's sent one night by kind of the
bully kids and they're like hey why
don't you go get us some water uh you
know and you have to go to this like
creepy sort of cistern or whatever like
in the basement or wherever it is like
in this really creepy area and so they
go there with him but then they abandon
him because they think that's like funny
at which point uh carlos hears
whispering like very ghostly whispering
and basically it says saying something
like many of you will die or most of you
will die or something like that which
obviously like uh freaks carlos out a
lot now so carlos runs away and gets uh
swept like kind of scooped up by this
dude named jacinto
who is this like he's kind of like i
think he's like the groundskeeper
and he was once an orphan there himself
i think one of his like his fiancee
conchita she's a teacher there and he's
also banging uh the older woman that
owns the place like with her husband
that like runs the place so and you can
tell from the jump that he's like really
not that nice of a dude like i said this
is very much like pan's labyrinth where
you know the humans are kind of like the
worst people so you can tell he's uh
pretty much a dick so he catches carlos
but carlos won't um he's just like you
know i basically i just came down here
to get water so he doesn't like gnark on
the other kids that made him go down
there so that kind of like endears him
to the other children because he didn't
like rat them out right now something
that's going on in the middle of all
this too is that jacinto
he's because because he's been there for
such a long time he knows that somewhere
in the orphanage there's like a little
cache of gold bars which as i said this
orphanage is run by kind of like an
older couple
and they're uh very much like on the
republican army side so they're kind of
like keeping this gold you know for the
cause or whatever and that's kind of
what they say
but yasinto of course just wants it for
his own self because he thinks you know
he grew up an orphan he was perhaps
treated badly so he's like well i
deserve this so i'm gonna try and steal
it so while nobody's looking
he's always kind of like searching the
place for the gold um he knows it might
be in this kind of safe so he's always
kind of trying to bust it open so he's
always doing that kind of stuff and
while that's going on carlos is also um
you know hearing more stories about this
ghost and he actually does finally end
up seeing him like right up close you
know what i mean and like i said the the
look of it is just great he's just like
a creepy creepy kid and carlos of course
is terrified but as i said just like in
a lot of del toro's other movies it does
actually turn out that even though this
ghost looks
terrifying um and he says creepy things
like many of you will die he keeps like
repeating that kind of stuff so
obviously carlos is like freaking out
about it but it actually ends up that
this kid is really kind of like warning
them and is only kind of like
misunderstood is not really trying to
scare them it's just trying to get like
some information across now another
thing that carlos finds out too while
he's going through like it's kind of
like a sketchbook of one of the other
boys whose name is uh jaime who was kind
of like one of the bully kids but then
he was a little bit older and then like
he endeared himself to him later on but
he was kind of going through his stuff
and he finds this little sketch in there
of like a boy
who's like laying on the ground or
whatever with like blood coming out of
his head and it's marked
and he's like okay well maybe jaime
knows what happened to santi and all the
other kids don't know because you know
he seems to know that santi is probably
dead right and then while that's going
on too there's also like i said this
whole kind of thing about the one of the
guys that originally brought carlos to
the orphanage who was one of the
republican army like sympathizer guys
that had been friends with carlos's dad
he actually gets taken
by the nationalists and they bring a
bunch of them to the orphanage and like
execute a bunch of them uh at which
point the the couple that are like
running the orphanage are like yeah well
if uh if that guy said anything about
all the gold and [ __ ] like that we have
in here we're [ __ ] so we really need
to get all these kids and pack up and
get the [ __ ] out of dodge so that's
pretty much what they start doing
however uh jacinto the groundskeeper
finds out about this
and he's basically like well i'm not
leaving without the gold so you better
tell me what it is uh you know where it
is and he gets a little bit rough and
violent and everything and starts
telling like the older guy that hey i'm
[ __ ] your wife and [ __ ] all this
other kind of crap uh at which point
they kind of like kick his ass and tell
him to get the [ __ ] out so they kick him
out now uh so they do that and then like
they're trying to pack all the kids up
and get him out of there like before the
nationalist army comes through or you
know the national sympathizers come
through uh so they're trying to get them
all out of there and then
unbeknownst to them jacinto has kind of
circled back around and has come back to
the place and while everybody's packing
up like all the kids and everything he's
like searching for the gold and then
he's gonna like burn the place down
whether the kids are in it or not he
doesn't really give a [ __ ] all he wants
is the gold his girlfriend tries to
shoot him but like she gets knocked down
and then like the fire starts and he has
put up like all these cans of gasoline
and all this other kind of stuff so the
you know the two older like two of the
older women that run the place they try
to get all the kids out before the ship
blows up but the ship blows up and a
bunch of the kids end up getting killed
and a bunch of the you know staff and
stuff like that end up getting killed as
well but you know the the main core of
kids is still okay
and they're basically like
once they start talking about
what happened and once carlos like
confronts not so much confronts but like
ask jaime hey what happened to the santi
kid uh because jaime seems to be the
only one that knows he says well you
know me and uh me and santi were down in
the basement or like near the cistern or
whatever and we were kind of just down
there farting around like looking for
slugs or whatever and jacinto comes down
and uh jacinta was trying to like open
the safe where he thought the gold was
and jacinto saw them so but uh jaime
kind of got away like before um before
yosento could get hold of him so he
starts like saying desantis like you
know
don't you know don't you say anything
about this or i'm gonna like kill you or
whatever but then like he pushes the kid
and the kid like smacked his head on the
wall and he basically like killed the
kid he didn't like if he didn't die
outright but he was like laying there
and wounded and then he was like well
[ __ ] this and then he like waited the
kid down and like threw him into the
cistern and then like his body was never
found so now that
carlos knows that
this ghost the one who sighs is actually
santi and that something happened to him
like he was murdered and he actually you
know him whispering all the time like
many of you will die he was actually
trying to warn them that jacinto was
going to blow the place up and was going
to kill a bunch of the kids and that did
actually end up happening so he is now
like not really afraid of the ghost
anymore uh because he knows hey that was
a kid and he got murdered and he was
just trying to give us information he
wasn't trying to scare us so at that
point he basically
goes to santi like the ghost and says
what do you want and santi says that he
wants uh yasento because yasinto was the
one who killed him now it ends up that
most of the like pretty much everyone in
authority at the orphanage has you know
been killed um so yasinto is pretty much
there with two of his accomplices
and the kids are there and he just kind
of like locks them in a you know a thing
and a lot of them are still wounded like
from the explosion so he just like locks
him up in there and he's just like well
we're going to lock him up in there
until we find the gold and then we'll
just burn the whole place down or blow
it up or whatever and [ __ ] the kids
because they're orphans and no one will
care
so they do that but the two guys that
are his accomplices they're kind of like
sick of hanging around here and they're
like look there's probably no gold it's
like we've been here forever looking for
it and it's like just whatever so they
just take off with the [ __ ] car so
then jacinto is just left there by
himself now it turns out though that
while all the kids are kind of locked in
this storage room or whatever
they're all kind of getting together and
they've got all the piece together like
all the story about santi and what
happened to him and they said look
yasento killed santi uh so he he's just
gonna kill all of us like once he found
the gold so we really need to like team
up and you know get rid of this
[ __ ] and that's essentially what
they do like all the kids kind of team
up and that one of them is able to get
out they you know one of them lets the
other one out and they uh basically lure
jacinto down to where the uh where the
cistern is and you know they they have
like sharpened sticks and stuff like
that and they just basically attack him
and then they call santi so sante can
come and like take him away and it turns
out too that jacinto actually does find
the gold the gold was actually hidden
in uh the older woman that runs the
place
um i think her name is carmen uh it was
hidden in her
hollow let she had like a fake leg you
know like a prosthetic leg uh the gold
bars were hidden in there uh so he
actually ends up finding them but right
before like the kids attack him and give
him to santi and santi like drags him
down into the into the cistern and like
drowns him uh and ironically like when
he first falls into the cistern it's the
gold is like weighing him down so he
can't get back up right away and letting
santi like come down there and get him
so
as i said i kind of feel like when
people talk about uh guillermo del
toro's movies one chronos doesn't get
brought up a lot and like i said i will
eventually do a review of that too
because that's a really really good
movie also but this one i kind of feel
like more people talk about like pan's
labyrinth and the ones that came a
little bit later but this one i mean if
you liked pan's labyrinth this one is
very very similarly themed
it's set during the same time period you
know set during the spanish civil war
and it very much you know it has a kid
uh at the center of the action and a kid
who you know this one is a lot less
fantasy based like i said it's more it's
more like a very very sad
ghost story like a revenge sort of story
more than like a fantastical kind of
thing but the themes of it are very very
similar and as i said this is just it's
a beautiful like haunting
really really sad movie and it has
honestly one of the best ghosts in any
movie ever i just love the look of that
ghost it's just so so great and it still
holds up today even though the movie's
like 20 years old the special effects on
santi the ghost like just looks so so
cool and it's just so creepy and just so
haunting there's just something really
really i don't know just the whole vibe
of it is just really cool and like i
said if you like other movies that you
know this gets compared a lot like i
said to the others which came out the
same year and you know like i said later
the orphanage which uh del toro also
produced although he didn't direct it
that has like a similar kind of vibe so
if you like that kind of stuff but you
haven't seen this one uh this is
definitely one that you need to check
out because it's just a great like
mixture of kind of this historical
ghost story with you know a real heart
to it and it's just like it's very very
sad and it's just oh man it's like it's
really really good one of the best ghost
stories ever made uh like i said i love
all del toro's stuff and i feel like
people don't talk about this one as much
as they talk about pan's labyrinth and i
get that because pan's labyrinth is
amazing uh that's another one i need to
do one of these days but i feel like
this one gets overshadowed a little bit
and that's a shame
so if you haven't seen
the devil's backbone uh please check it
out i actually rented it on youtube but
i think you can find it like pretty much
any streaming service you would care to
find it on so please check it out and if
you've seen it uh let me know what you
think about it in the comments and that
will do it for this installment and i
will see you guys on the next one
bye
[Music]
you